gee it sure is boring around here my boy
this peace is what all true warriors
strive for video games we know them and
love them and so do you
it's taken a while but we finally got a
game ourselves you'll never finish this
game is falling apart no it's not shut
up you're letting everyone down no I'm
not I'm gonna make this game and it's
gonna be the best thing that anyone has
ever seen but nothing is without sin and
that includes games even our own one
game not this game because we're nothing
but fair here at cinemasins here's
everything wrong with free point hi the
game based on the book the Abel's by me
Jeremy only the best novels are turned
into video games which is why there are
so many first person shooters based on
the works of George Eliot plus there's
the Ulysses RPG that one's pretty
confusing you can play as Alex or Emily
the Dick and Jane of 21st century
suburban youth and these characters have
the absorption power of rogue the arm
cannon of Megaman and the jumping skills
of a frustrated fleet just kidding I
don't think you can blame the bad guys
for these steam blasts that one seems
like it's on the school also exactly how
is this labyrinth in school full of
doodads funded property taxes in this
town must be through the roof the trash
cans are beautifully rendered those
stairs are clearly stolen from Mario oh
the custodians belt it can hold blood
and a giant keyring fascinating in fancy
form around foliage oh I could just jump
on these guys the Able's has loads of
sexy glamorous locations like a cave an
elevator shaft
and of course a parking garage oh this
little guy reminds me of the game from
The Brave Little Toaster oh but I want
to blast it open with my arm cannon ooh
boo
is that a cinemasins t-shirt I can't
tell if this is subtly breaking the
fourth wall or a cartoonist product
placement by the way reading nice
practice room someone's seen the x-men
movies why can't you just absorb this
guy's powers aren't you an absorber why
not avoid traffic altogether by you know
walking on the sidewalk this has a
subtle reference to Arrested Development
and a book spoiler on Chad's shirt add
two cents
I'm not sure what to do with my
hands-free point hi buy it on Steam to
play at home and buy it on iOS and
Android to play when you're sitting on
the toilet at work hiding from your boss